et
[Musique]
les shadoks que se sont réfugiés sur la
lune mais l'atmosphère de la lune est à
l'intérieur de la lune
comment dont les shadoks pouvait-il
vivre et respirer il n'avait pas de
petits tuyaux
il ne permet pas d'être ou comme les
forts qu il ne vivait pas l'intérieur de
la lune non des shadoks sur la lune
eh bien il respirait avec leurs pattes
une pâte pour inspirer une pâte pour
expirer
c'était même assez pratique étant donné
qu'ils pouvaient faire les deux en même
temps sans se fatiguer à dormir
assurément il y avait un petit problème
mais il fut très vite résolu grâce à
l'invention géniale du professeur jadot
qu'au bien connu maintenant sous le nom
de machine à dormir debout
mais vous vous rendez bien compte qu'il
n'aurait pas été sain de respirer même
avec les pieds une atmosphère toujours
enfermés alors on était obligé tous les
dix ans dans trois semaines un mois de
mettre l'atmosphère dehors pour lui
faire prendre l'air c'était quand même
assez dangereux parce que lorsque
l'atmosphère était partie se promener la
lune naturellement se dégonflait mais
revenons à notre histoire
les ja doc donc avait résolu de se
plonger d'anéantir gégène et de
l'exterminer
[Musique]
mais on ne peut pas dire que la lune
était comme qui dirait une plateforme de
dire adéquat pour exterminer les choses
avec précision
d'autant plus qu'avec ce machin là on
les voyait venir d'assez loin et surtout
la nuit comme par un fait exprès pour
plus de sécurité dit gipi avait quand
même planté quelques graines de radars
autour de chez gégène les radars jpy
vous le savez de pouce est tout
simplement de la terre comme des
géraniums ou du buisson lit et comme
toutes les plantes de cette espèce se
mettaient à pousser justement à la
proche de la lune c'était président
suety gégène était aussitôt prévenue et
agissez en conséquence il n'y avait donc
pratiquement rien à faire pour
exterminer geiq par la voie des airs
mais heureusement il y avait les fameux
chat d'oc note
[Musique]
et
m